my name is diverse career from Nairobi
Kenya associate Oakland workshop Farrah
and Anna Chaka Fattah on public
environment anxious and I think really
the failure to meet a consensus from the
Copenhagen conference last year gives a
little demon cancel our globe in Allah
community development and particularly
for Africa where the mitigations and the
challenges of mitigations and coconut
with the impact and effects of climate
change are enemas and we have seen these
things happening especially the extended
droughts and really coconut with an
expectant downfalls you know which are
living to African status unmanageable
and we have seen really lots of death
anything from the perspective of the
effects of climate change loss of income
and livelihoods for people and I think
it's the high temple government's a
global the leading to rethink on the
future of the climate change